hey guys sitting down with Alexander
Ludwig who you may know from The Hunger
Games of Vikings made his Abercrombie
model days but right now he's starring
in a new thriller called a black way you
say that again you're gonna need to do
mmm
doctor it's a character piece and a it's
a Western in a way you know it's a dark
thriller that's about just a group of
unsuspecting people who grow to form a
family with a similar goal
what's Anthony Hopkins life like pudding
what you guys talk about one of the most
modest and great human beings you could
ever meet me so good to everybody to the
entire crew it really was one of the
greatest Fleming experiences of my life
Alexander is known for his array of
roles from Bjorn on Vikings to Cato in
the Hunger Games
who do you think would win in a fight
Bjorn or Kate over the Hunger Games yeah
you were almost Peeta yeah oh my gosh
that was um yeah it was between Josh
myself and another another actor we went
with Gary and he gave me this
description cater things like which you
uh would you want to read it yeah I love
to play badly so fun and we read it and
immediately also when I read it I was
like oh well this is just perfect
I'm really really happy that it turned
out the way it did
especially with Vikings because had that
happened you know for me it's like I
really had to work hard and then when I
got when I got that show when about
Vikings are you I realize how much more
a Delon know and it just feels like be
honest Jonah everything kind of just
happened really for the reason you know
and I really had to learn what it takes
be great no and I feel like if I had
been plunged into something like that
before for four films it's just I
wouldn't ever have appreciated what it
takes to you know I hadn't honed it
you